one do you think that the Democrats
should have waited until they'd seen the
transcript in The Whistleblower before
they move forward as Nancy Pelosi did
last night no I think that based on what
we know and what has been proven in
terms of the release it's not a
transcript per se it's more a memo
written of people who understood or
heard the conversation I think that they
were exactly right you know today
apparently the White House talking
points got leaked to some Democrats but
I think it's leaked far they were
accidentally so I guess it was leaked
but I think you know just listening here
I think boy those talking points they've
made the rounds because the reality the
accusations original here we go asking a
foreign government to investigate in a
political rival is illegal it's illegal
it's a violation of the conjugate that
for media matters want and the
Constitution the president should
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States by the way this isn't
just so he's supposed to look away
there's potential corruption how's that
particular you can't because you accused
us of reading talking point here's what
here's what it is Judge Napolitano who's
our senior in New Zealand he says what
does he say you don't need a quid pro
quo you just need to ask a foreign baby
making conversation it's not only that I
mean you stop and think about Pelosi
says this is lawyer lawless Mitt Romney
said extremely troubling it comes from a
republic and of course yet you get a
situation where the President of the
United States is saying I want dirt on
my political opponents and only a year
oh it's because we can't beat you at the
ballot boxes because these worried about
a table from us yeah to me
ergo rage and it's unbelievable that
people would try to throw up exactly
what you've been able to say a word who
were on this show yesterday we weren't
why'd you have your shot let's talk
about two things that you brought up
sure said that it is illegal for a
president to ask for dirt but from a
foreign agency or a foreign government
Senate Democrats sent a letter to
Ukraine in 2018 asking for them to
investigate President Trump by
cooperating with the Special Counsel
investigation so if Trump is guilty of
it well so are the Democrats that seem
like you did sorry I'm good yep all
right so you implied that the CIA that
the the transcript was not properly
transcribed the people who wrote the
notes were CIA agents were brought in
from the CIA to do this we know that
people who are have done these things
before have said on record today that
this is the closest you're going to get
to a transcribed yeah there's a
situation so on to the political aspect
of this you know the word favor has been
tossed around a lot in terms of the
transcript of people accusing the
president of giving a favor and asking
for a favor of Joe Biden being
investigated he actually uses the term
favor when he's asking about your
Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election and let's not forget that it
was the DNC who went and met with
Ukrainian officials in Washington DC to
ask for dirt on President Trump on
behalf of Hillary Clinton that's the
first thing the second thing is the
president this week has been able to set
up a huge contrast when it comes to what
Democrats are focused on and what he is
doing he's been meeting with a number of
leaders we had Secretary Pompeo stand up
and say we've convinced a number of
allies that the Iran deal is no longer
the way forward with Iran so while he's
doing this on the world stage and having
serious conversations about the security
of the country the Democrats are focused
on impeachment based on a
script but they didn't even see till
today and continuing on with the
narrative while the president's actually
focused on serious issues that affect
the country and voters are going to be
the ones who decide if that's morning
well last month they I can't remember
which poll it was but pretty they're
pretty much consistent across the board
that sixty or sixty percent or more of
people say they are not for the for
impeachment that they don't have the
appetite for it because they would like
to see other things get done